et passer au sujet suivant c'était un
très grand moment d'émotion c'était
témoignage d'hélène de fougerolles qui
est revenu sur sur ce qu'elle a vécu et
que ça avec sa fille surtout sur le
comportement des pédopsychiatres avec
avec elle et la façon dont expliqué est
ce que avait sa fille et la dureté des
mots des propos franchement c'est herman
extrêmement bouleversant émouvant voici
un petit récap on a pas d'autre
alternative que de la mettre dans ce
qu'ils appellent un hôpital de jour
c'est un centre un institut médical pour
toutes les particularités qui sont liées
à ce qu'ils appellent le handicap mental
ça aussi ça certains mots comme ça qui
eux qui passent pas qu'ils passent pas
encore aujourd'hui parce que mes fils
est handicapé mental pour moi ou
déficientes mentales et c'est les mots
qui me viennent encore flou de vie
c'était très serré
son témoignage extrêmement courageux
version je peux faire une idée
la télévision vous aimez vous l'avez
raté non mais volontairement parce qu'en
fait je ne peux plus aujourd'hui
malheureusement regarder ce genre de
choses parce que je sais ce qu'elle peut
ressentir et je suis déjà mois dans une
souffrance aussi différente dans un
combat différent et malheureusement si
si en plus je prends tout le combat des
mais je m'en sers quand les choix c'est
une protection fait défection protection
maintenant est ce que ça vous touche une
personne peut dire comme ça prenne la
parole ce livre c'est quand même c'est
plutôt bien pour ce faire danser les
joueurs aussi ah oui je trouve ça super
parce que c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on
essaye nous de faire à notre niveau à
nous petit donc sur les réseaux comme je
disais son instagram et c'est vraiment
ce qu'on veut faire
donc je trouve ça bien que des
personnalités comme elle et plein
d'autres si on nous entend fasse passer
le message parce qu'il ya trop de deux
maladies rares ya trop bien trop de
problèmes de santé non résolus et c'est
important d'en parler
le djia vous avez regardez ce reportage
sipa regardez ce reportage c'est des
choses qui me touchent
monfils qui vous concerne et luigi
physique cardiaque qui est aujourd'hui
résolue mais en tant que parent quand on
entre dans ce cercle du milieu
hospitalier en est confronté à plein de
questions que répondront les
spécialistes
mais d'autres questions très humaines
pour lesquelles on n'a personne avec qui
communiquer parce que parce que notre
maman nos frères nos soeurs nos cousins
n'ont pas d'enfants malades
donc ne peuvent pas rester seule à nos
petites questions et on se sent seul et
on a tous cette envie de donner le
meilleur pour notre enfant et ça devient
notre cheval de bataille comment offrir
à nos enfants la meilleure qualité de
vie possible
comment est ce qu'on vous a annoncé que
votre enfant avait une pathologie j'ai
eu un excellent médecin
moi j'ai appris la pathologie de mon
fils il a une tétralogie de fallot c'est
4 malformation cardiaque et je les a
pris au septième mois de grossesse mais
le cardiologue qui me faisait
l'échographie m'a pas dit votre fils est
malade et m'a dit il à poser l'appareil
à échographie et l'asie on va le sauver
votre fils dans une même phrase il
m'annonçait que mon enfant avait une
pathologie mais en même temps qu'ils
avaient de l'espoir
alors c'est pas du tout été le cas je
demande rôle qui nous raconte comment le
médecin le pédopsychiatre lui a dit ce
qu'il en était et franchement les mots
employés sont hallucinants regardez
alors il nous dit que déjà si un enfant
ne verbalise pas l'âge de 5 ans il nous
parlera certainement jamais que il se
peut qu'à l'adolescence elle devienne
schizophrène
enfin il nous dit plein de choses donc
elle est foutue forcément voilà donc
foutu ok qu'est ce qu'on fait devant la
petite qui comprend c'est pas un légume
forcément vous avez du mal encaissé
c'est vrai ça c'est déjà la première
chose qui paraît absolument incroyable
mais je me serais même pas qu'un médecin
pouvait au départ que par la suite non
seulement il me dit que c'est foutu
je vous reprends ses mots mais qu'en
plus les mythes c'est de sa faute
pas de culpabilisation qui est
hallucinante regardez fois dénoncé m les
théories sur un sur l'autisme c'était
comme quoi
l'origine de çà était sur la
maltraitance
donc moi je demandais j'aime et je ne
suis pas maltraitante me disais
maintenant au contraire vous en faites
tellement où je les ai entendu tellement
j'étais nouveau fait d'armes en éclats
du profit qui est au fond je savais que
c'était pas vrai et que et que c'était
une enfant qui avait besoin d'être prise
en charge de cette façon j'avais très
envie de me enfoncé un couteau dans le
ventre je pense que c lire la
culpabilité à la maternité c'était très
j'avais l'impression que ça allait me
soulager terrible ce qu'elle raconte est
tellement courant moi j'ai été je suis
proche de francis perrin et jacques
sentent qu'ils ont un petit garçon
autiste peuple qui est maintenant grand
c'est exactement la même chose
il essaie de culpabiliser les parents
comme on ne connaît pas l'origine
au lieu de ne pas culpabiliser on a dit
quand même on a osé dire à francis
perrin que c'était peut-être la
différence d'âge avec sa femme
vous vous rendez compte quand vous avez
un enfant comme ça et qu'on avait dit ça
en plus
la culpabilité face est hallucinant et
pareil on a dit que le petit serait un
légume louis va très bien c'est
quelqu'un quand on parle avec lui d'une
richesse oui les sons différents
mais c'est francis perrin dit que c'est
un cadeau fardeau et je trouve que c'est
magnifique c'est aussi un cadeau et
voilà il y a beaucoup d'espoir dans le
livre d'hélène ce jour le site clubic
on a parlé dans un peu en loge vous
parlé très librement de sofiane de sa
maladie des conséquences éventuelles
tragique on est devant lui je vous le
dis mais ça me ces voix là non plus pour
gérer ça alors déjà j'estime que dans la
mesure où si c'est lui qui souffre de la
situation ces nuits qui peut pas marcher
comme les autres petits c'est lui qui a
des douleurs etc
ils méritent de savoir exactement ce
qu'il a de le comprendre de savoir
pourquoi il se bat tous les jours et
quelle est sa différence avec les autres
parce que les autres malheureusement
nous lui dirons donc je veux qu'il en
soit conscient et je veux que ça le
motive ça le motive à se battre tous les
jours aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec sa
maladie donc je le redis l'ataxie
télangiectasie il a effectivement une
espérance de vie limitée
mais il est aussi consciente que il
sortira du lot et que sofiane voilà
sofiane sera avec nous longtemps pour
nous enquiquiner mais effectivement une
espérance de vie limitée à 20 ans mais
il va sortir de la norme et puis on va
tout faire pour de toute façon c'est
pour ça qu'on est là c'est pourquoi
qu'on ne trouve des solutions derrière
donc bien sûr c'est facile c'est sa
femme en tant que maman de toute façon
le je le soutiendrai jusqu'au bout je
ferai le maximum pour lui jusqu'au bout
et tout ce que je demande aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il soit heureux si c'est un
petit soleil
allez on va avancer avec allées du
missouri soleil ali benflis un soleil
non à côté de ça on est une famille
heureuse j'ai trois enfants mais à la
voilà on n'a juste pas le même passé
tout en vidéo sur une note positive
regarder shana à 5 ans et un jour alors
que vous jouer à cache cache
elle se plante devant vous qu'elle me
dit te caches michel et ses premiers
mots simon avant m'a dit qu'elle
parlerait jamais et là avec son grand
sourire et me dit tu te cacher et je
suis dit qu ou quoi et elle me fait de
cash ni chez et que sa petite voix est
jugé jeudi je sais pas quoi dire
et du coup je le prends en rien je dis
je m'appelle pas michel et dégage toi
même elle éclate de rire te caches mais
je vous dis ça veut dire va te cacher
c'est ça voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai
rencontré la voix de massy rigolade